that's why everybody hates josh costa
yeah like literally that guy dude yeah
watching him fight pissed me off that's
why i dude when tyrone woodley knocked
him out i think i [ __ ] died
i was so i was like there's a god yeah
you in five four three two one hello
everybody como estas uh muy bien hey hey
but you just asked how are you doing
uh
so
welcome to another episode of the genius
brain podcast we have edric and we have
alex acosta here
you want to meet somebody who gets into
the most random hobbies out of nowhere
he'll be like powerlifting one day and
the next day is like hey but you know i
just started crocheting
are you trying to give someone an oven
mitt real quick bro and my mom did teach
me how to do that once i was a point
guard i was never that was never like a
hobby i was trying to get it
you just over here just [ __ ] watching
the movie just knitting some [ __ ] oh
yours is
no it was between bowling or uh i don't
know bowl and arrowing or what's it
called archery archery
it was between bowling or archery yeah
[Applause]
but so the reason why bowling number one
is it's fun as hell right you can go
with a lot of people yeah and archery is
expensive so like one of my homies
started doing it and like he was like oh
yeah get get one oh [ __ ] and i looked at
the price i'm like i think i'm a bull
bruh
but i was just telling david like i got
battle wounds already and [ __ ] like my
knuckles call it battle bro we in the
field out there so like it gets
dangerous out there in the street you
know what i'm saying so
i just this is such a very unique
personality because i've known alex now
for years when he gets into something
then [ __ ] get into it bro it's
not like oh i'll just go pick up a
random got a custom bowling ball i saw
the inserts and shot i knew this
[ __ ] would right from the gate
you already got your custom ball made
and everything you're not bold my whole
life okay i like not like where we're
going all the time right but i've always
used house balls and house balls are
whack as [ __ ] yeah i guess i didn't know
that yeah until like i started bowling
um and my homie was like you should get
a custom ball because i was like [ __ ] it
let's do a league right yeah like the
thing is i miss competing from
powerlifting right so i want to do
something where i can compete in and
it'll just be fun you know so then
bowling so i get the custom ball and i'm
like damn so like yeah i've already
learned like so much [ __ ] about bowling
yeah it's like oh that's 5 10 15 20. you
want to aim at your rights right right
yeah yeah i don't know how many steps
you you lead into this uh i take i think
right now i'm at four four okay uh but
i'm more traditional yeah i've been
watching like some of the people are
like at five some two-handers or like at
two some but some some people got like
that the mini step in two they they got
eight ten steps into it see
allah exactly yeah
just trying to make him swinging legally
on the line
i can't believe you got in the building
but anyways the topic that we're gonna
talk about is some [ __ ] that has been on
my mind like we haven't done a ufc fight
podcast in a long time which a lot of
people have been recommending even
people who don't watch fighting and i
only i think the reason why is because
of how much we love this [ __ ] right and
if you guys don't watch fighting that's
completely okay um it's violent like
muriel hates looking at it because it's
so bloody yeah
but
this last fight card was something very
very special
i'm still hyped about it from the la and
i always say this every time we talk
about that this was the best card ever
this was the best card ever bro honestly
and it was because like
even them it wasn't like particularly
like stacked yeah but the fights were
just so [ __ ] good bro and they're
just like the stories of what happened
it was it was insane yeah well no i was
just gonna say like um
this this is coming from like me being a
fan of mma
before what it is now i feel like right
now there's a lot more people who are
kind of watching it as a sport but you
remember back in the days when
blockbuster video days when uh you know
ufc used to be next to faces of death
yeah yeah yeah yeah and there were no
rules like punching people in the door
punching was the most hilarious
like they would literally have somebody
in in a
had an arm choke yeah and the defense
was ballpark
no weight classes no bubbles no gloves
dick punch it was the craziest thing
ever which is why i [ __ ] loved it i
didn't get to see it often because i
didn't have like cable or anything else
like that somebody would record it on a
vhs and they would show me right and i'm
like dog this is the best thing ever my
dad a black box baby we was watching the
[ __ ] thing dude
back in the day
he's like oh i got that cable guy who
you know you just you slip him a little
something you get that for you so ufc
278 was very important because there was
two two fights that were coming up right
if you guys don't know there's a guy
named paulo acosta paula costa is
[ __ ] jacked like
he looks so huge he doesn't even look
cute yeah i met him in person before and
like even bar or david because you've
been around bart and he's powerlifters
right we've met some big people yeah
when i met paula costa cause my homies
train at fight radio in arizona i was
like yeah this is like one of the first
people i'm meeting like bro how the [ __ ]
do you make 185 right right like he was
huge as a middleweight right yeah so in
his previous fight he missed the weight
by like 25 pounds
yeah
he broke records like you've never seen
a fighter coming 25 pounds heavier it's
just not happening and so he fought a
guy named marvin vittori marvin vittorio
won he was like [ __ ] i'll fight you
at any weight class so they basically
fought it like heavyweight i feel like
marvin tory got something loose
he's he's unstable bro yeah he's mad and
he was the perfect matchup for him
yeah he's he's like a brawler but he's a
lot more technical than him so i i
didn't imagine paul closely winning that
fight at all yeah even in his bigger
bigger size he was going to take out
marvin vittorio but and that's generally
what happened so
up to leading this fight there was luke
rockhold so just to give you guys some
background information luke rockhold is
a former strikeforce middleweight
champion from force came to ufc won the
middleweight belt again yeah his legacy
is actually pretty crazy yeah when you
see the way that people talk about him
now they kind of judge him off of his
last two losses right so he got knocked
out because he went up to light
heavyweight by john bachowicz who became
a champion right yeah and then who was
that uel
romero
knocking the [ __ ] out yeah these two are
very unique specimens though
romero he's one of those same dudes
where he looks huge for his weight class
i don't understand how he's going to
fight yeah he's gigantic yeah cute uh
the cuban wrestler cuban boxer yeah
cuban missile crisis or something that's
what they call it
that's there i think there is a fighter
called the cuban missile prize yeah yeah
yeah so yeah i know it's uh
that's the same like
you forget who he lost to so i think
that was like the whole thing right now
for leading up to this fight was like oh
this luke rock will have a chin yeah
he's like but look who he got knocked
out by right right some scary [ __ ]
dudes who were legends in their own
right and like for me too i had to look
back at his record and you know i would
talk about luke rockhold's chin but i'm
like hold on a second look at who he got
knocked out by yeah joelle romero and
also john bochovich so
different and he was in a weight class
that wasn't his class exactly so he took
he took a three-year hiatus which is a
really [ __ ] long time and his first
fight is a killer like
yeah that's what he said what he wanted
though he said he felt scared and he had
to think about who makes him feel scared
and that's what got him up in the
morning and motivated to like really do
this now the the craziest thing about
this fight if you guys have it just look
up clips on youtube it was a bloody
[ __ ] mess that [ __ ] scene when he
just
and then like blowing up it was it
reminding of the sea from fight club
remember when uh brad pitt's character
he lets leave yeah
and he's like we really want to stay
here a little and he's just a little bit
like getting blood all over his face i
was really i wouldn't even be surprised
if he took it from fight club yeah yeah
probably yeah and luke rockhold has been
notoriously known to be terrible on the
mic he says some really corny stupid
[ __ ] yeah it's easy to make fun of 100
after like when he was coming back i was
like yo i'm [ __ ] excited and then the
press conference happened i was like
i just want to see you fight yeah he's
like i'm a [ __ ] samurai yeah he
reminds me like steven a smith because
he's using random big words out of
nowhere and i was like man let me tell
you something about this like over here
this this i'm a samurai i'm a ninja when
i slice the air the air doesn't even
doesn't brush i know i was like oh man
shut the [ __ ] up please but he's been on
this weird tip because he's
rooms yes
dog he came out like he was in a zombie
movie i'm like yo what's with this
fool's face what happened to him
he by the way is like i think he was
assigned to diesel he was uh yeah he's a
male model a male model he's right now
uh i think that contract's up oh yeah
but he made millions off of that okay
that's good at least he got his money
really
like literally it was like the two of
the best looking dudes in the ufc
fighting each other yeah
you got ricky martin yeah
someone has dana they're like are you
gonna put the belt on the line basically
like the hottest
hottest outsider yeah hottest
[ __ ] yeah dog and so watching
these two's fight was crazy because
the way that luke rockhold was talking
about paulo costa he was he had some
hate for him yeah i [ __ ] hate this
dude and by the way for somebody like me
like paula costa
i never he's never going to get the belt
like the way that he fights how hard he
gets tagged yeah and you're seeing now
in this fight
they were fighting at elevation in
colorado which was so apparent with
everybody
except kamaru and leon which was
surprising which was [ __ ] nuts yeah
we'll get into that yeah dude if you
have ever wanted to watch a a crazy
fight just watch this luke rockhold
fight in the first round gassed i know
right there yeah hey bro tell me if so i
don't when you noticed when i noticed it
right it was like after like a punch had
landed from costa and then all of a
sudden luke had like his mouth open and
his mouthpiece was out yeah and i was
watching with my dad i'm like oh [ __ ] he
broke his jaw and then like 10 seconds
past i was like oh no i think he's just
[ __ ] guys
i looked at the time of my god
for like two minutes exactly we're not
even out of the first year yet i was
like holy [ __ ] funny [ __ ] is too when i
was watching that i'm like oh politicos
is doing pretty well and then the moment
the second round hit paul costa was
gassed yeah i was like he was tired of
the first round two and it hit him in
the second yeah both of them were
exhausted in the second [ __ ] round
yeah and then also too the crazy thing
is luke rockhold got reversed he
reversed his position on the ground from
pawlikosa so yeah
yeah i was surprised here's the reason
why i didn't want pawlikosa to win that
fight right was because paula cosa was
getting cracked by a gassed out luke
[ __ ] you
one clip of him he goes he's circling
the cage and he goes [ __ ] you hits him
with the overhand
it's like a little brother mad at his
big brother
but he like [ __ ] multiple times you
know he rocked close to like three four
times like almost had him knocked out
and honestly it looked like rockhold was
going to give up at one point for real
when he put his hands on his knees and
he just like no i was like yo what is in
the middle of a fight really hey you
want to just giggle for no [ __ ]
reason do a watch a replay of this full
doing the craziest uppercut to his balls
oh i know right and then casa's over
here trying to be like oh this wasn't
even illegal
i've never seen a tiger uppercut to a
nut dog that is probably the hardest
punch in ufc history yeah he [ __ ]
took that [ __ ] from hell and shot it to
heaven
and then
he still fought yeah and he he only took
maybe like a 30-second break and he goes
no i'm ready to go let's go yeah i know
at that point too i was like bro take
five take the five minutes man take the
full five but i don't know about you
guys but like
i've never really been a luke fan
especially because i was such a bisping
fan you know when they fought even both
times i just never really liked luke but
yeah after this fight i'm like bummed
that he retired
because i'm like bro you actually for
being exhausted after like a minute of
fighting and you fought that whole fight
yeah and it wasn't like you got blown
out of the water yeah like that was kind
of a close fight yeah he and then i
think he answered the questions because
even me like i was always like oh he
probably doesn't he don't have no chin
he don't have no chin he got cracked by
caution he hits hard for sure and so
like now i'm like bro if he stuck around
he could probably beat some of these top
middleweights yeah like he was supposed
to fight strickland i'm like damn he
probably could have yeah beat that he
probably could have won that fight
uh it is a bummer but uh yeah like
that's when i when i was watching this
fight i was like it is crazy how tired
he got knowing like the team that he
trains with so i wonder like in my head
i'm still thinking like i wonder if
something else was up yeah because like
i'm like [ __ ] like well the three year
layoff the three factor right because
you can't emulate what it's like when in
a game time setting you know you're
sparring in all that you're not going to
go as hard as you're going to go
especially against a guy like paulo
right he's who's a huge dude who's going
to be he's going to mess with she goes
forward right who's going to pressure
you for me too like
politicos stock dropped so much for me
because he he almost lost straight up to
a 37 year old dude that had a three-year
layoff that's on shrooms 100
brother honestly that's what i was
saying i was just talking about this
yesterday i was like
this didn't really look good for costa
dropped way low rockhold actually got
the w yeah
i feel like people
feel like more like me like oh no [ __ ]
don't retire keep fighting like yeah you
know like super emotional because
watching him fight through that
exhaustion
it kind of motivated me i'm like look at
this guy he's inspirational for sure
because he kept saying this where he's a
samurai and a warrior
and the fight i was like
yeah you are cute
you are literally dying on your sword
like you are a i get it why do you keep
calling yourself a samurai now yeah
cause it's true when he said this in the
in his interviews i didn't really think
about it he goes
and when have you ever seen me exactly
yeah oh [ __ ] he has never tapped he has
never given up he's gotten knocked out
but he never said i'm quitting yeah and
he made a point in that fight he could
have quit way earlier which again looked
like he was going to multiple times
his body language is like i'm done i'm
and then he comes to the [ __ ] yeah
like there was one point he like even
turned around
like a body shot yeah like the whole
like turning around yeah he grimaced i
was like i was like oh [ __ ] right he's
done then he came back and cracked him
almost knocked him out again yeah i'm
like dude cossa you suck i wish you
wouldn't retire i'm not like the biggest
luke fan but i would love to see him
fight when like his conditioning is good
and [ __ ] because i'm like
bro you did that and then you as you
know like when you're tired and
exhausted it's even easier to get
knocked out it's easier to crumble to a
body shop do you almost want to get hit
yeah and he was just eating that [ __ ]
bro and i'm like bro like because he's
so skilled like especially like his
ground game and [ __ ] it is kind of a
bummer because like
we've
like when i started paying attention to
him was the bisping fight right so i
seen him get knocked like really paying
attention to the fight when he got
knocked out yeah danielle yeah you know
then john so you're just like oh [ __ ] it
but when he actually fights and you see
he like skill like his heart and [ __ ]
you're like bro he could do really good
yeah
for anybody in the division yeah but i
think for him too
he's already proven his point in this
division and he probably has another
good year left right so for him his why
is gone now yeah so it's just hard to
get back into that cage i mean
especially in the fashion that he did
dude when he rubbed that blood in his
face oh yeah it was from when he was he
had his back taken by closer and he
turned flipped around yeah position got
make it as dirty as possible if they
gave it to rockhold i would have been
happy oh yeah i would honestly i
wouldn't have been mad yeah anybody both
did the same
it was a close fight honestly i honestly
was surprised that how far it was
towards costa yeah i thought it was
gonna be maybe like a 29-28 and then
like a split but the way they scored it
i don't i don't yeah i don't know i will
say that
this is like i feel like
one of the only times that you ever seen
somebody retire on a loss
but it's like good yeah they're like oh
[ __ ] yeah cuz like he just went out and
showed the [ __ ]
and didn't get finished you know so he
answered all those questions he answers
questions that he never quits you know
all that type of [ __ ] so like this was
like the best way to go out on a loss if
you're gonna go out
it really couldn't have been more epic
than the wake
right and at the end him showing the
motion just being like look guys i'm
done yeah you know i did my thing i'm
done yeah like no one cares about costa
yeah exactly like everybody's talking
about you to begin with anyway the thing
about costa the reason why i don't like
him as a fighter is that
he has has yet to really evolve i mean
yeah his ground game got a little bit
better here and there right
but
nothing has evolved from his striking he
still gets cracked really [ __ ] hard
and you're seeing like even in these
fights before when cosa would get
cracked he'd be kind of wobbly he got
wobbled hard on this one it's starting
to wear him out a little bit oh yeah he
needs to switch it up the thing that
annoys me about him all the time is
every time you know it's a good shot he
always sticks out his tongue like like
like it didn't do anything but that's
what he know it was a hard shot yeah
yeah exactly there's this [ __ ] it sticks
on his tongue yeah he's like if he
didn't do that he wouldn't have gotten
wobbled so hard yeah
because we've watched the sport for so
long you've you don't get to see
fighters
who take hits like that and still
survive besides romero yeah romero's
just unique he's one of one fighter like
he'll get kicked in the head full blast
and then he'll just be like what's the
problem yeah
you see right it's like and what exactly
what your point is is like
no matter who you are you can always get
knocked down you can always get it man
you can get it anybody can get it for
sure did you guys think with the another
person that you guys hear me talk about
this guy named jose aldo he's been
fighting wc champion one of the greatest
of all times especially to defend his
belt uh in the ufc
uh
legend yeah did you think that uh jose
aldo lost what he won i thought
um
it's it's weird because i'm like in my
head how i score fights i think jose
aldo won i thought he won two i i
thought he won i thought it was like a
draw
yeah even closer to that i would i would
have been happy with that yeah but i
thought josie all the one um i think
like
he defended i think almost literally
every takedown yeah right they i don't
even think they gave him a takedown
because the one looked like one so yeah
it might have been yeah zero takedowns
like 16 take down he he defended
everything well and and at that point
i'm looking at like who's doing the more
effective striking then right right
josie aldo it's stan and it was i
thought it was jose aldo yeah what was
the other guy's name robbed dewilish
philly yeah it's like such a complicated
yeah but it's just like i don't i feel
bad because i'm like
i still i i thought jose aldo won but
like now his last couple fights i just
don't know if he could be champ again
yeah yeah i just feel like back back in
the day jose aldo was combos output he
was aggressive yeah i just feel like he
slowed down and like that's exactly what
i was gonna say yeah ever since i feel
like the knockout with conor he's just
kind of went through some [ __ ] yeah and
he's like slowed his pace down has
become more careful a little bit more
strategic but like from people watching
from score standpoint that could make it
seem like you're not doing as much
activity whereas this other dude
constantly was pressuring and and look
there wasn't like anything any major
hits landed here yeah but it looked like
he was doing more work and i think
that's why he got it i mean if you look
at the just
significant strikes maraud had basically
nothing exactly yeah so
it's a bummer yeah and it's just like
in that sense i feel like if jose aldo
could just put combos together there was
like i remember i still remember the one
combo he did like a one two and then the
body shot no it was a body shot
it landed so flush i'm like that's all
he needs to do is just throw combos but
i think like what you said after that
conor fight he turned more into a
defensive fighter yeah where he's always
waiting to counter um and it's worked
but it's just like
definitely a championship the elevation
got to him too you could tell yeah
around because even after he well paced
himself third round he was gasps
the defense of the takedown and stuff
now for barab that's the sad thing about
for marab is like after this fight his
stock went down exactly nobody gives a
[ __ ]
like i don't want to see you fight ever
again yeah which it kind of sucks
because yeah he has great takedowns his
wrestling his grappling is amazing
and the problem with him is that josie
aldo is notoriously known for his uh his
defense yeah like it's really really
[ __ ] hard to take [ __ ] josie yeah
and
just it sucks when you win and then you
get nothing from it exactly because i
wouldn't care to see him fight exactly
it's just it's same story with costa
right it's like they those two they they
lost all right they won back to back
it is a bummer and especially like
because my rob and the whole thing with
him and aljo they're like best friends
and [ __ ] and like they both kind of have
a similar style where it's never it's
never really like
that exciting right you don't even
really want to watch them fight that
much and you're just like all right and
then these are the two guys that we're
dealing with now that are at the top
that
could be the chance that's why everybody
liked khabib so much yeah habib was
grapple but i'll smash your [ __ ]
exactly he was aggressive with it yeah
that's how you're supposed to that's why
people also like islam islam goes in and
he smashes you out yeah it's not just
holding you against the cage and
controlling the octagon which a lot of
people if you watch the ufc
you know listen i appreciate all aspects
of mixed martial arts but even then for
me sometimes it's like come on yeah like
this is this is much you're just holding
position just to hold it and you can
tell because you've watched so much mma
right and you've been watching it for so
long and we've trained even though we
don't really do grappling but we've seen
it we can tell when someone's holding
somebody and they're literally just
holding just like positions that's like
everybody hates josh
like literally that guy dude yeah
watching him fight pissed me off that's
what i do when tyron woodley knocked him
out i think i [ __ ] nutted
and then [ __ ] paul daley who retired
yeah he went to belladore belladore
bellator
[Laughter]
paul daley too if you watched his last
fight at bellator
he'd retire with a knockout i know bro
it was amazing that's the way to go
really he hits hard dude
baby doggy is so [ __ ] hard it's
unreal his hands too look like mickey
mouse yeah
some people are just gifted
man yeah they're like wide and just like
that's why bro he's punching you and
he's covering like your whole face
it's the size of your face coming at you
yeah
the the craziest fight that happened
though man oh yeah kamara usman
look up this guy's pedigree guy has not
been defeated in what sixteen nineteen
after sixteen or nineteen fights uh yeah
yeah uh
i think sixteen are i think fifteen and
going to six yeah
yeah and that doesn't even count those
ultimate fighters because they don't
count those
exhibitions so like he's technically won
like almost 20 fights yeah 20 fights in
a row yeah unstoppable this guy
extremely high accolades for wrestling
and grappling right a nightmare to deal
with which is his actual nickname that
the nigerian nightmare yeah um also a
little corny on the mic not a not a big
fan of his mind yeah his mic game is
pretty weak he talks to me yeah yeah
yeah who are you trying to serenade
right now bro he's always doing this too
yeah looking oh my god
you don't understand i'm a dog
he always says
everybody tries to take me down they
don't know me yeah they don't know what
i read this comment that had me died
somebody says kamaru usman talks like
he's telling a story over campfire
i hate that bro i don't know why it bugs
me so much though but he always says the
name joe listen joe they don't know me
i'm gonna go over here and i'm gonna do
work joe i'm like i keep
is literally the worst and i got to tell
you too the one thing that i'm not
looking forward to because leon edwards
became the champion leonardo was even
worse than him bro there's sometimes
it's almost like a stipe [ __ ]
oh what the [ __ ] you just said
you're good at fighting
yeah
you know i'm gonna get the belt up
he mumbles so much he needs like a like
a dictation coach because it's not like
his accent like the uk accent or
whatever wherever he's from it's the
fact that he doesn't he mumbles all of
his words he does not enunciate yeah so
it just i don't know what the [ __ ] he's
saying no so he needs somebody to teach
him how to speak on the mic
in general isn't it crazy when you hear
them talk but like i'm sure if when he's
back home people understand i'm like
yeah yeah like easy i'm like bro how do
y'all understand sometimes even when
patty's talking right right [ __ ] yeah
accent is pretty thick yeah you know
like god damn they use all these weird
words and [ __ ] for certain things you're
like they're slangs they're they're
english like remember when mcgregor got
his leg [ __ ] broken and they were
interviewing after yeah i was like i
don't know why
so i didn't understand what you were
saying and then finally people started
translating it on the bottom and then i
could hear the words yeah
so if you watch this fight kamar usman
is a nightmare to deal with he was
[ __ ] up leon edwards four rounds in a
row arguably one where he he actually
got taken down by leonardo yeah that
first round was really surprising yeah
and i do i personally feel like it did
it was more in the sense of it took
kumaru off guard right
i don't think you expect it because when
they were when they were like uh
clinched up yeah just standing straight
up yeah it was just like he wasn't even
thinking like oh this man's about to go
on a on a you know for a take down right
right um but then when he had his back i
don't know about you but i was like this
oh [ __ ] he might get this yeah
because like it doesn't really seem like
you know justin gates is in that camp
too and like what i've heard about
justin gaichy from people that i know
that have worked with them they don't
train any jujitsu
so he doesn't justin gaetje i don't know
about the same for kamaru but it seemed
like jiu-jitsu wise leon edwards was
doing better yeah and at one point i was
like oh bro he's about to submit kumar
uzman and kamar uzman his first loss was
by rear naked exactly
he's about to get him right now but then
yeah obviously after that round the
table in my mind i had
i already assumed that kamar usman was
going to win but i wanted leon edwards
to win so if some you know i was asked
like who's who who are you betting on
i'm betting on leon yeah yeah but
it's just camaro is so hard to deal with
he's pretty much good everywhere and you
know the funny thing is is that i did
agree with leon in an interview the one
of the few words i could understand that
he said
but he said
he's fallen in love with his striking
and literally that's what happened this
whole [ __ ] fight was a movie because
you see this guy dejected his coaches
yeah in his face yeah get your stop
feeling sorry for yourself yeah come on
leon yeah keep in mind if you guys don't
know his nickname is rocky it was like
rocky's story man
you know stop feeling sorry for yourself
and you know dean um what's his face
said the best thing he goes you could
tell that how
terrible he's feeling because he can't
even make eye contact and i didn't
notice that until he mentioned he was
looking away and he wouldn't look at his
cause he was so ashamed of himself yeah
and then that next round he goes stop
[ __ ] feeling sorry for his get your
head in the [ __ ] game yeah like and
then dog fourth round comes in
and i [ __ ] you [ __ ] not
ed park was with me and i go
the left kick it's there the whole fight
just [ __ ] throw it who cares and i
say that and he throws it i stopped we
looked at each other i was like
he hurt me
the only reason why i thought and i'm
not sure if people noticed this too i
assume that the left kick was there is
because he kept scooping yeah for that
for that low excuse me dog the left kick
is there you're a southpaw
launch that [ __ ] who cares it's the last
round yeah and he [ __ ] yeah and i
think one important thing to point out
in that moment too was it it was one of
the first times kamara was backpedaling
he was pressuring leon the whole fight
but he got a little complacent he just
like taking it easy and it costs man and
i do want to say this too because i had
somebody i was talking about this fight
particularly yesterday at the shop
and they're like damn it's so crazy
because it was just like such a normal
kick i was like no
i was like so then you don't really
understand
kickboxing striking then right i'm not
even saying i'm the best striker or
anything like that but i want everybody
if you think it's a normal kick to try
and mask your right right behind your
right hand right where there is
and it's so [ __ ] hard there's only a
couple people that do it really well
like robert whittaker does it really
well that's one of his favorite things
steven wonderboy thompson carlos condit
did it yeah leon edwards obviously um
there's that fighter brian battle he
just fought a couple years ago yeah yeah
that other guy but like that shit's so
hard and
and it wasn't it wasn't like camaro
technically
wasn't doing anything wrong
in the sense of pairing the cross right
but because that skill like that leon
has and he's able to throw that combo
yeah like the perry was perfect uh
camaro bob perry's comes off to the side
yeah just that that kick was so
perfectly placed and hidden yeah that
man it was it was i remember i got kind
of heat when i heard this place oh it's
just a normal kill i'm like
i want you to go [ __ ] try throwing
this [ __ ] bro because i bet you you'll
get your ass knocked out trying to do
that [ __ ] right that's so [ __ ] the
reason why that kick was so technically
beautiful was that
i can try to do that kick right but
you'll see that kick coming from a mile
away
it was like a half second yeah it was
literally fake the jab yeah through this
cross and the leg was coming yeah oh boy
you could even see it on the cross
he's not even making a fist it's like
kind of open-handed because that's what
the setup is for right yeah
perfect yeah literally made kamar uzman
right barry right like that's the goal
is right
but and you're coming right over and it
made him comfortable you're always
heading straight
too late it's such a
it's it's a great technique a lot harder
to do than you think it is because a lot
of people are like well more people
should do this yeah a hundred percent
but it's just really hard yeah yeah
you should do something
yeah
like you just said too it's like
at that point
like because because mauro was doing
good with his striking right but he
wasn't like technical it was just like
at the point of leon was always worrying
about these takedowns always on his back
foot but then uh i think also dean
thomas had said something and then dc
agreed with him it's like uh
kamal could take this round off yeah
easily yeah
he's like but he's not going to and dc
was like yeah of course he's never going
to do that yeah i feel like that's
actually what cost him in this fight
exactly
100 percent he could have just went and
held him up against yeah
yeah
he was it's not like he was really
pounding him when he was on the ground
either so if he did one of those things
where he just yeah he wanted to knock
out a hundred percent that's why leon
was right you fell in love with your
striking and the thing about that is too
when you look at all of kamaru usman's
knockouts right and the way he's done it
emphatically the reason why these things
happen is not because his striking is
amazing it's because the threat of the
take count takedown is
not there so people have to worry about
so many things with him i mean just to
give you an example right there was a
part in this fight i'm not sure if you
guys remember where he fainted
a leg grabbed yeah and then he went for
it and then
he was like yeah yeah he just went for
it yeah it was so weird that is how much
he has people worrying like even when he
faints they were afraid that he was
going to come up top so he just gave him
the leg and he goes yeah oh i have the
legs yeah i'm just going to grab it yeah
and he took him down that whole last
round he could have pressured forward
and took him to the cage and smashed his
face out
by the way yeah that's what something
habibi would have done of course yeah
i will never give you an opportunity to
win exactly and kamar usman gave him the
opportunity he stayed at kicking race to
a southpaw yeah
very dangerous with his kicks yeah leon
edwards is has been practicing mma he
has no other modality of fighting no
karate no nothing no kickboxing base
it's mma that's why he is one of the
best most well-rounded fighters in
so crisp so [ __ ] chris you would
think that he trained like traditional
muay thai yeah but he didn't it's just
he's just been doing mma and that
[ __ ] left kick was shin to hell oh my
god the most perfect kick that you could
ever land on somebody right now like
yeah there's like oh you see just all
these [ __ ] switches i saw this meme
and it was like the perfect because he
was knocked out with his eyes open right
yeah his eyes were wide open so there's
this meme and the guy's like this and
it's chris tucker's body and it's come
on
he's like what's your name
there was one that i saw that had me die
and it's not even that funny i just
really like this song that people have
been using it's like one of those trends
i really enjoy but he gets knocked out
and it's a picture of camaro usman with
his eyes open and it's the song i want
to go
yeah
but it's it's cool like i've never
really been like the biggest leon
edwards fan
but like seeing him win and like you
know you got to see his whole story on
the countdown right his dad was murdered
when he was 13. because he was like a
drug dealer and [ __ ] like that he was
going on the same path so and i would
never know because he always tells a
story but i don't understand what he's
saying yeah exactly
leon edwards yeah exactly yeah i can
know what the [ __ ] is going on but uh it
was cool to see him win you know and
then like he's like talking on his phone
with his mom he's like crying all that
type of [ __ ] look at me now yeah and he
made a point where i was even in my head
i was like i was that same way dana
white was like if kamar oozeman isn't
here colby covington's your champion
right like bro we all kind of wrote off
leon edwards yeah he showed us how
[ __ ] good he was in this fight
because he was getting taken down but he
was getting up like there was a lot of
times he was great yeah he was getting
up and he was at some points making it a
striking fight but like for a while
until that last minute he was nervous
because of the takedown yeah and like
jorge now like [ __ ] i've wanted that
fight right i'm like jorge you about to
get your ass
[Music]
yeah the thing about leon edwards and i
think i became a big fan of fan of him
after the even though it ended in a
little bit
yeah when i saw how bad he was [ __ ]
up below yeah
[ __ ] dude
man yeah he i mean you could talk about
that dq all you want he was going to die
yeah yeah and you see what belittle's
doing now or below he's doing now right
he's just mauling everybody he couldn't
take leonard down and leonardo was just
lighting his ass up i think that's when
you recognize how great a fighter is is
like when a certain type of fighter you
see this type of fighter doing something
all the time but he can't do it against
that's another fighter and you're like
oh he's just having an off day no it's
just he's that good yeah you know we
always talk about this too um or people
in general always wear this they always
say that
the downfall of any person is their
pride and ego and you could see it in
kamar usman and i didn't really want to
believe it but that's what leon kept on
saying he goes your your head's way too
big because
hollywood yeah
literally
it's too big of a target man i'm gonna
crack that [ __ ]
he legit told him to where he says
there's levels to this [ __ ] in wrestling
like you could be doing it as much as
you want but you're never going to get
to my level guess what same [ __ ] goes
for striking right same [ __ ] goes for
striker you thought that you had your
elite level style of wrestling with your
striking because you fell in love with
your knockouts you were not leon edwards
yeah but not edward striking is crisp
it's so good i got i got really hyped
when i saw uh the pad work of leon was
throwing those elbows i know that was
nasty yeah when he was doing that [ __ ]
and then someone's made a clip now where
they're putting it together because he
finishes with the left kick yeah and so
it's like the elbow elbow elbow and then
right when the left kick is about to hit
the pad it's him knocking out kamara
who's right right like he's just yeah
he's one of those guys where it's like
what you just said i think kamal who's
been fighting jorge knocking him out
early and then the two fights with colby
right was just a striking fight but
they're both not strikers
kind of probably got to his head a
little bit that he's an elite striker
right yeah
and all that [ __ ] you know but he's
going down the tyler woodley path
because he started acting and doing the
rapping [ __ ] yeah
yeah i don't know what he dug i don't
know what the [ __ ] tyler woodley was
thinking like you're a terrible rapper
yeah and i'll say it to your face
[ __ ]
he's actually he's actually really bad
yeah
like [ __ ] bryce mitchell's way better
than that yeah bryce dude yeah
surprisingly bryce mitchell actually i
was listening to show my oh you have
some hardest [ __ ]
bro yeah yeah you got bars yeah yeah i
can't believe bryce mitchell this
[ __ ] but honky tonk boy is better
than
now but i think the cool thing with leon
like i said because i was never a big
fan but because of this showing it
really puts in perspective like
like even for me with hamza i still was
on the train like hanzo about to just
run through everybody i don't give a
[ __ ] yeah now i'm like man leon's a hard
fight for him right yeah i still think
leon now oh leon's a hard ass [ __ ]
what i remember hamzat uh leon said i
want hamza yeah because he couldn't get
fi well let's talk about that for a
second too how [ __ ] i've never seen bad
luck
with such [ __ ] luck like this guy i'm
like how does it's it's almost like you
should have scripted yeah like how does
this happen to you time and time again
how many fights was he not able to do
and then he gets coveted and like you
know
literally dana white said himself he has
the worst one i've ever seen he said he
said i've never seen anything like that
tony ferguson is one of the bad luck
people too especially with his fights
with habibi yeah
that fight was cursed with them leon
edwards is just cursed in general any
fight he was trying to do it just was
not happening for him and what exactly
what you're saying it shows also why
leon's so dangerous because in his
mindset when they finally started
talking about it right i think it was an
interview with ariel helwani he was like
i don't care it's just gonna make it so
much more sweet when i win the title
yeah so like he didn't even care he
wasn't letting any of that affect him
he's like oh i don't care just makes it
even better when i win the title because
i've had to wait so long so i'm like
people people did a compilation clip of
leon edwards uh getting yelled at by his
coach and kind of losing the fight being
dejected to the wind brought teared up
oh [ __ ] this is beautiful dude
it's a movie yeah it's literally
rational like he's not talking about
anything technical he's just trying to
motivate this guy like come on man you
know who you are like [ __ ] dig deep
man this is what you wanted screaming
into the camera everybody doubted me you
said i couldn't do it well i'm [ __ ]
here i'm the champ that [ __ ] made me
feel so [ __ ] good and they were
playing the rocky music too
music
he
did such an amazing job at that and like
just to show his heart and that's why i
like this card so much you saw it from
luke rockhold and you also saw it for
[ __ ] leon edwards you see heart and
heart has a lot to do with the sport
like just going in and training
especially in his position too like you
have to
he got zero respect from everybody and
he hasn't lost in 13 fights yeah 13
[ __ ] fights that's what's great and i
was kind of on that train too where i've
kind of just like leona where it's
whatever yeah just write them off yeah
cause we haven't seen him fighting so
long
we just had to be reminded but i think i
think the reminder did come back in the
nadia's fight even though you know nate
slipped in that last shot to wobble but
like he was dominating me throughout the
whole [ __ ] fight but that's also like
the luck thing right yeah he did so good
in that fight and all everybody ever
talks about yeah
right yeah
he almost got knocked out though that's
somebody who lost stock yeah
but he actually knocked him the [ __ ] out
in the last round
dude this this
this sport is so [ __ ] insane all i
could say this past weekend was this is
why i love the u.s right [ __ ] insane
matchups dude i love this sport so much
watching that [ __ ] was like
every all the years that i've spent
watching the ufc
this is why yeah i am [ __ ] loving it
i feel like for people like us too that
have been watching it forever right if
you're just getting into mma you're kind
of lucky because like you're seeing like
we're just getting the top athletes now
kids people that have been doing it
forever
when we were watching it back it's like
tank habit like so [ __ ] dude
was the reigning it was like that's cool
because you could watch people fight but
yeah people weren't particularly skilled
right yeah and then but we've got to see
like so many generations of like even
when chuck and randy and like leota all
those people coming up jon jones is
beginning right you got to see all this
[ __ ] and evolution now it's just right
now like like i don't know if you've
been watching the tuesday night
contender series yes
like last night bro they had some
crazy like like 21 year old you're like
dude this kid is so [ __ ] good he's
been training since he was like five but
he's been training mma and that's the
difference now is you're getting
in in ten years this sport's about to be
wow
kids are starting like a three to five
year in mma it's not like oh they did
boxing and then they're going to start
wrestling when they're 18. it's like
they're doing everything to be an mma
that's a great point to make because
like it's becoming more of a traditional
sport yeah right where like you said
people have an aspiration from kids like
oh i want to be an nba star like when
we're growing up like five years old
right like i want to play in the nba
whatever now these kids are like i want
to be a fighter yeah and then they have
now the the gyms and stuff in place
where they can actually train at and
learn these and it's just also the uh
the physical science behind everything
is so developed now yeah right so
there's no well you know when i was
weight training in high school it was
just more weight more weight more weight
no break days no nothing uh you would
jump from you know benching 225 and then
you add another 45
players you know and i tore my shoulder
that way and every time i injured myself
i just kept injuring over and over and
there was just no just physical science
behind this stuff everything is so you
can get stuff on apps and phones now
yeah so you're seeing these athletes get
better and better faster and stronger
and because they're doing things way
smarter more efficient way more
efficient so that now like i followed
this kid named joseph brown and this kid
is like a taekwondo champ but he's also
like a boxing champ and he puts both of
them together
he's a taekwondo champ and a boxing
champion
his hands are amazing and i didn't even
know because i was falling for his
boxing [ __ ] and i was like wait you just
need one though okay yeah dude then he
started kickboxing
he's like i think he's like 18. wow
you're gonna start seeing that a lot
more now yeah like in the next like 10
15 years
it's like i feel like it can either go
two ways like the fights are going to be
so [ __ ] sick or they're just going to
be like so even that you're kind of like
yeah
but like like i think in like two weeks
there's a 17 year old fighting on dana
white's tuesday night consistently wow
he's a jose aldo yeah you're just like
bruh it's it's crazy you're gonna see a
lot of these fighters too just kind of i
think
adisanya is like the prototype for
somebody who's very very well-rounded
yeah right yeah and then we're seeing
we're gonna see a lot more of these
arasanas yeah amazing striking amazing
takedown defense um but the one
obviously he doesn't have so much the
grappling sense well he hasn't he
doesn't need to yeah
yeah but they just can't get to his legs
yeah right yeah he's so long right yeah
super long and just all the fates and
stuff too uh what's his teammate fought
uh that big gigantic oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah i forget his name though oh um yeah
carlos olberg what was it called this
old no it was the kid who won with the
front kick to the gut oh um
is he's teammate i don't know he hasn't
fought in a bit but he's a part of city
kickboxing he's a big ass like uh uh
like polynesian dude i think he's a
mixed polynesian kid okay and he won
with this [ __ ] front kick up the
middle yeah super hard yeah yeah yeah
yeah amazing dude that was one of the
other card fights right it was one of
the prettiest yeah
we're [ __ ] fired yeah yeah this whole
card was insane i i that same night i
went to the garage i started punching
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah i'm not gonna lie
after leon [ __ ] knocked him out i
tried to emulate the same combo i almost
hurt myself bro that shit's hard
i [ __ ] hurt my hip
there's a clip of me throwing a head
kick which i thought was pretty dope and
i saw the the the clip i'm like
hiding your kicks behind a punch is so
hard like that's top it's it's top level
you know you have to have some skill to
do it you can't just like i've been
doing kickboxing for two months i can
throw that combo like it's harder than
you think man fighting is so weird man
and like
some people too they take like i feel
like we do it for fun right
sometimes like when you spar some people
who take it so seriously it kind of
annoys me actually only recently we're
not saying names but yeah you were there
too but i was you know kind of going at
it with a friend of ours and you could
tell like
usually when we spark it's very
fun and casual yeah but there was a
little switch that happened and i was
like
you're taking this a little more
personally than it should you know what
i mean and i think it like hurt his
pride or her ego a little bit well
specific well first of all did you get
him with a shot i got my luck
but it was escalating to a point they
didn't have to and i remember as we were
sparring like
dude like we talking [ __ ] yeah and that
you know made me click a little bit i
was like oh we're not having fun anymore
yeah right and that's when it got a
little because i remember too there was
this part where uh
listen i've lost i kick a lot right and
so in a boxing sense i probably won't be
able to do much but if we add kickboxing
it's just a different game yeah right
also i'm a lot more fit so
literally got to if i remember i i
connected i hit him with a with a check
hook and a crotch he goes that was like
you didn't do [ __ ]
yeah
i was like
what's going on right usually it's like
oh that was tight but he was talking
[ __ ] and i when i had to sit and think
about it like why did it get to that
point
and i think with somebody like him
is that fighting to him is everything
he is the guy that fights really well
you start taking that away from him it
starts [ __ ] with his eyes especially
when it's against someone that's oh i
train three times a week and you know i
do this for fun and i'm just a fan yeah
and then it's someone that's like this
is my life and then they're getting
pieced up by it
yeah i see and it's it's just listen
i'm not amazing at this sport right but
i do have a competitive edge and i'm not
terrible right and also too
as i get coached and look i'm not doing
this often right i mean we haven't
trained in what three weeks yeah right
we train maybe once twice a month yeah
right but i also really love this sport
i'm also not going to let somebody just
walk me down and beat me up it's just
not going to happen right like oh
samurai
through air yeah you know all of us too
even though for us
i think when we get better it takes a
lot longer but but we are getting better
a little bit by a little bit because
we're not really competitive
he has to cope with the idea that guess
what we're going to start
matching each other yeah because i
wasn't going to stay here the whole time
yeah but you know we sparred before and
it was always a wash he would always
just take me out yeah but now it's
starting to
level out a little bit and he's feeling
it i was like oh maybe that's why he got
a little upset yeah because it was oh
david's not hitting me once or twice
like it's a lot now yeah it's a lot it's
like check crosses [ __ ] like 10 body
kicks back straight kicks to the head
low kicks everything yeah yeah so
for me it's like oh so you were okay
with it when you were beating me up
exactly you know but when you were
beating me up i was like oh this is dope
and so this is
[ __ ] but then now that the levels are
starting to even up a little bit it
starts to hurt their ego yeah and i just
thought like oh i didn't really like
that too much but he's not really coming
out that much anymore i noticed it
sounds like it sounds like he you made
him feel insecure man but he shouldn't
though cause he's still better than me
yeah it's just but but you can't you
can't control you know what goes through
somebody's mind when they start to feel
like they're getting attacked well in
this sense literally and figuratively
right i think that's what's good though
about like especially like our our
main training group we don't really ever
have egos right
like i'll i'll i'll spar and i'm
literally not i'm just gonna sit there
and let you [ __ ] hit me but in my
head i'll throw like a couple shots and
those two land on my
it doesn't matter to me i'm like i know
i'm sparring this is the time i'm about
to get hit like a [ __ ] ton i think i
think what the mindset here is having
fun and learning versus winning and
losing yeah
yeah exactly i don't care yeah and the
thing is too i also have a certain level
of realization right let's say alex and
i spark right
i'm longer and that right now i'm a
little more cardiovascular i'm a lot
more familiar
[Applause]
in a real fighting sense if he hits me
it's gonna be a problem
like i've had this full like hit me
maybe thirty percent and my [ __ ]
forearm was crying you know so i
understand like in this sparring set
like let's say we did a real [ __ ]
match i don't think it'll i don't think
i'm gonna win just because i know that
if he throws a full kick at me even if i
block it yeah it's gonna make me act a
little bit different
you know i think different i think david
would be able to keep me away oh with
this one but that's the difference is we
don't really have like an eagle oh i'm
gonna [ __ ] everybody right right and i
feel like sometimes because it's
happened we've had other people come in
where they have these egos and then
they're going all hard and all this [ __ ]
and still we're like just staying
composed but it's like bro chill yeah
we're trying to get rich people yeah
we're just trying to chill and train man
like you [ __ ] taking it so
serious yeah and i think that's wise
because they take it so serious and like
what we said
we start like doing [ __ ] to them and
they're just like what the [ __ ] this
[ __ ] shouldn't be doing this
yeah yeah
it's like well you know if you turn it
up then we'll turn it up too exactly
it's like i understand that you know you
know this person too like skill-wise is
better than me but i'm not going to let
you just do [ __ ] you know what i mean
it's just not going to [ __ ] happen
you know what but whenever you [ __ ]
get a group of guys and it's a physical
activity there's going to be that
machismo there's going to be like that
flexing that happens some some dude is
always going to be an alex tate right
yeah
like that's what it's going to do what
was really cool is uh jeff
yeah jeff was so dopey yeah like
yeah he came in and i i was watching the
video like that boy was like pissing me
off but it was awful it was never like i
never felt like oh damn he's trying to
like prove something you know because i
landed a couple shots too here and there
but like it would never because i've had
sparring matches too where you're
feeling like i'll land a couple things
and i feel like the power level goes
from here i'm staying here but then all
of a sudden they're right here yeah and
i'll stay there the whole time you know
like i'm just like whatever like let
them [ __ ] do their [ __ ] but like he
was really cool and like you don't get
that that often where someone will come
in and be so controlled and just you
guys can flow and have a good time dude
pro mma fighter comes in super nice guy
and i'm getting tired and when you get
tired you throw a little harder but you
just slipped it and you just tap tapped
exactly and eventually i just felt like
throwing up
so i was watching that video and it
reminded me how tired i got because i'm
like bro like he moves so much so it's
more of like you're missing and you're
getting tired and you're like [ __ ]
there's a really great clip that you
could see of him just dipping he fakes
and he throws a overhead and he pulls it
and he just taps me in the face he could
have blasted me to another universe dude
but as a pro fighter he's he knows his
skill level and he wants us to have fun
too yeah and even before he goes hey on
these spa rounds
have fun he goes do more head movement
do the stuff that you probably typically
wouldn't do in a fight because this is
where you get to have fun and experiment
move your head a little bit work with
head movement you know throw a little
more stuff and it's all good like don't
worry about being perfect and i think
that's what happens to us because
we're we're looking at so much in a
fight sense that we think that if we get
touched we're knocked out yeah but he
goes even if fights it doesn't happen
right right right right right you know
you get tapped you get touched by me you
yeah i remember like
we were throwing kind of hard but the
difference was he was like hey pretty
dope and i limped away
i couldn't walk for like four
days i still remember when i did that
one random [ __ ] fight i did this one
random muay thai fight like on like a
week and a half notice right and i still
remember because i lost um but
afterwards like i was fine right like i
felt good like i had like this little
bruise on my on my um my forehead but
then the guy came like the the guy that
i fought came and he was six five like i
think he was gigantic former d1 football
player yeah i am and i'm five six right
so it was a big difference but like i
had a pretty good like towards the end
of the last round because that's when i
started hurting him uh but like he was
limping and limping like because i i
started landing these locations these
leg kicks
i was at that point i was like boom just
throwing him hard and like he came by
and i was like hey good fight and he
just was [ __ ] blew me off and his
coach was like yeah he came up to me he
saw her man he's really mad because he
like hurt his leg and i was like yeah
we're fighting yeah we're fighting you
[ __ ]
also too like i'm not just saying this
that guy was running out of the [ __ ]
time
yeah like a little [ __ ] i don't want to
hear [ __ ] right you suck so mad
so much because like i was my goal was
to try and close them off so i can try
and land some [ __ ] on the inside
because right in the beginning like
right when we started
him just right down the middle i'm just
feeling my head going boom boom boom
boom and there was a separation i'm like
[ __ ] this long as [ __ ] bro and like
because he's really long and just
talking about knock you out yeah he's
not even supposed to be like immediately
it sounds to me like it reminds me when
you did what you're describing of like
bob sapp remember back in the day where
he would come and that's what it was
yeah he's like oh [ __ ] it was such a
whole thing i know we talked about it
before but like when we got there we
were supposed to be the last fight right
because we were the heavyweights yeah i
was just like all right cool and then
like one fight happens me and nikko
doing like maybe a one minute round of
just hands just to start like oh let's
keep you warm while we wait right and
like we're sitting there we're watching
these kids fight the fight ends and then
all of a sudden we're fighting i'm like
whoa what the [ __ ] so i had to run and
go find my shin guards put them on and
like we only had i think it was like a
week and a half so like we were like
this guy might be taller remember so i
was doing all these inside low kicks so
that's like what the first like round
and a half or like me trying to land it
and it was weird because i kept hearing
nick say outside go outside but i'm like
inside yeah inside like i just for some
reason it was hard but then yeah but the
outside look is what [ __ ] him up i
started working a lot i even made him
[ __ ] almost do a full 360 on one of
them yeah his legs are [ __ ] hard so
like the the problem with that is that
when you do these pkb matches if you
guys ever get to do one what's pkb stand
for um i don't know punk killer [ __ ]
yeah yeah
but it's basically these they're kind of
they're sanctioned i guess quote-unquote
but they're amateur fights shin guards
you can't knock people okay yeah because
that was so threw me off when you said
the shin guard so you do wear
and the yeah gets to decide when it gets
too crazy so there's not supposed to be
any knockouts if you knock somebody out
yeah yeah so it's kind of like an
exhibition then basically basically and
what's crazy is right
everybody in that building including me
open face head gear yeah the guy that
i'm fighting the biggest person in the
in the whole building has a [ __ ]
big-ass bar headgear uh-huh i'm like all
right he connected him with the super
hard overhand when the bar protected it
bro
that bar wasn't there probably broke his
nose like yeah no no because i felt that
when i landed
and when when i punch in my head when
i'm punching hard i'm always punching
through and this is the bowling ball arm
too yeah that's the bowling ball
like especially on the legs
but i remember feeling it in my glove
the bar just like pushing me like it
felt like my arm went like this oh [ __ ]
and i was just like oh you're so [ __ ]
lucky yeah but i remember because like
in my head like dude this whole meeting
like oh try not don't knock each other
out
he did not follow that rule bro we're
literally facing off keep in mind the
judges were at his coaches and then he
had his coaches and the ref was one of
his coaches
to face and the guy is like talking this
loud right he's like all right yeah yeah
you guys can go 100 um but if one
person's 100 is here and one person's
here we're going to stop it i should
like oh but in my head this whole like
almost two weeks i'm like oh it's just
gonna be like a sparring match right
yeah and then right when we start
right down the middle and i was like oh
we're fighting yeah yeah
but it took me a little bit to like
register it like oh [ __ ] your head gets
knocked out
okay the shitty thing about that for pkb
matches for somebody that has alex's
fight style is that alex lifestyle is
pressure he gets hit right so a lot of
that stuff is burst movement and when
you don't have corners to corner
somebody yeah you kind of limit what his
abilities are right because literally
it's it's not that
in the sense of in a cage where you can
run around a little bit i'm talking
about you step out they reset yeah
oh they reset so he was using that to
his advantage where he would step out
and reset every time alex would close
the distance yeah so literally i always
felt like
right when i got close i'm like alright
here's my chance stop reset i'm like
[ __ ]
those pkb matches do have that one like
weird caveat which they really dislike
so it kind of mitigates honestly what a
real fight's supposed to be like you
can't just like put your foot outside of
a square yeah it like completely kills
the rhythm and flow of it yeah so when
he did connect super hard with the
overhand and dude that leg kick [ __ ]
him up yeah but yeah he got he didn't
get the w or alex didn't get the w but
like i got one because like i'd say like
the whole first two rounds was like i
was like man this fool is long ass [ __ ]
five dude and then i kept trying to like
do the inside low kick and it was like
towards the end of the second
when i started throwing the outside and
i remember going back to the car and
nick's like bro that outside i was like
yeah that's there and then so the whole
third round that's when i was i kept
doing it i [ __ ] his leg up that's what
set up the overhand because i kicked his
leg he did like a turn started coming in
i dipped and i hit him with an overhand
it was pretty good and i was just like
yeah i just waited two wait so how tall
are you five six five
i went to the guy i was like cuz you
find out your opponent day up yeah i was
like hey do you have any other
heavyweights waiting he's like no we'll
let you know so i'm like chilling in my
car just like on my phone and then i go
back in to go to the bathroom and the
guy goes hey um yeah so we have another
heavyweight i was all right cool yeah
and he's like
it's him over there and the guy was like
over there yeah he's over there on the
back and i look on my all right cool and
then i can't find him we're just staring
at each other and i'm like
did i like need to sign something or
she's like no i just i just wanted to
let you know dude i was like
okay yeah like
[ __ ] you yeah
also he was kind of wack that the ref
was actually his coach right they were
all like all for him and [ __ ] after
every round what's [ __ ] up is after
the fight he gets the w mm-hmm and it's
his [ __ ] coaches who let him go that
hard first of all yeah right from the
because he wanted him and then he's
salty at you yeah bro i was like what
the [ __ ] i was like [ __ ] you won
yeah
i was like no we could scrap right now
no club let's go yeah all right then and
then this coach is like yeah you hurt
his leg and he was like limping he's
like you hurt his leg because i remember
when i was landing those kicks too i
still remember like throwing him and
feeling him land cuz i was literally
aiming just like right above his knees
yeah okay boom trying to make him like
chop inwards right and a couple of them
was like oh that [ __ ] was hard
like hell yeah dude that feeling well
guys that wraps up this episode of the
genius brain podcast i hope this has
been a long time since we did a fight
podcast but
if you ever wanted to watch a fight to
motivate you to get into mma you have to
watch 278 crazy crazy crazy you could
catch alex at lift guard was that three
f's uh two f's two g's maybe so you guys
do lift picks as well if you're looking
for photography needs he does all that
stuff for you hit him up book him get
that get that [ __ ] in there you just hit
up ed ed to edtwo
and also check out secret society
s-c-r-t-s-o-c-i-e-t-y
that genius brain secret society uh
collab is dropping super super important
one of my favorite things that i've ever
done in my life and you guys know i
rarely rarely ever drop
anything that has to do with you know
davidson comedy or genius brain and this
is the right way to do it so keep your
eye out for that pre-orders will be in
soon and we'll see you all next time
[Music]